- I heard that you were the one
that talked him out of his jitters
when you and Whitney were getting married.
Was that true?
- [Alicia] Yes. Yes, yes.
- [Bobby] Yes, she was at the wedding.
- How full circle is that?
- I know.
- Yeah. So wait, so you were,
everyone's nervous right?
When you're about to get married?
- That's what I say. Everyone's nervous!
- I was extra nervous.
- It's a terrifying kind of thing.
That you're like, it's a big step.
- It's a big deal.
It's a big step in your life, yeah.
- I just love that you
were like, you got this,
and then y'all end up married years later.
- Yeah isn't that crazy? I know.
I know, it's amazing. It's
the timing of everything
and why things are meant to be.
But for sure, I was there.
I was a friend and by
then all of his groomsmen
and his brother could not
get him out the bathroom.
So, I was like, listen,
we are getting this show on the road.
You know, we're here and this
is happening, and you know.
- Oh, they couldn't get
you out of the room?
Like, you had serious jitters?
- I had real, that's what
I was telling you Kelly.
- Okay, my God. I thought
you meant just, you know,
like everybody's like.
- No, I locked myself in
- (in unison) The bathroom.
- Oh my God!
Okay, okay.
- [Bobby] Yes!
- [Alicia] So it was fun for us.
- And I wouldn't come out.
I wasn't gonna come out for anybody.
- Did she know about this?
- I think everybody knew about it.
- Oh my gosh, that's terrifying.
So you're the one that ended up?
- She was like, he better
get out that bathroom.
But for some reason,
yeah, I came to the door,
I knocked on it, and I was
talking to him through the door
and then finally he like
peaked it a little bit.
And I got in, you know,
and it was like, let me in, let me in,
everything's gonna be okay.
And for some reason, you
know, he listens to me
and he eventually came out the bathroom
and went down that aisle, yeah,
but it is ironic that it
was us again meeting in life
later on and he would be my husband.
- That's so crazy. I love that.
It's like a really interesting,
cool romantic comedy.
I would watch that movie.
And you were in it.